[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quadriga coming
to you from the heart of Berlin
now the Middle East is currently on edge
with so-called Islamic state forced into
what looks like full-scale retreat
another longer term conflict is
intensifying with this man Saudi
Arabia's and Bechet ambitious young
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
confronting the other big power in the
region that is of course Iran the two
countries are already locked in a proxy
conflict that's impacting Lebanon and is
devastatingly Yemen but now the fear is
that the two strands of Islam they
represent Sunni and Shia could be drawn
into a greater conflagration so our
question on quadriga this week is Middle
East tensions a new war and to discuss
that question I'm joined here in the
studio by Jamshid for roogie senior
editor with Deutsche Welle farsi service
he says military support for Saudi
Arabia is just as wrong as abandoning
the Iran nuclear deal also with us is
freelance journalist and expert on Saudi
Arabia Peter berm who believes there
won't be a hot war between Saudi Arabia
and Iran and the warm welcome also goes
to Shandy rosana's from dw2 where she's
both a producer and an analyst Shani can
bring us the Israeli perspective on
things and she says in its ongoing
struggle against Iran it's not Saudi
Arabia that Israel is looking to but
Russia Jamshid Farooqi I'd like to begin
with you if I might and of course the
the tensions between Iran and Saudi
Arabia go back a very very long way but
why is this cold war now heating up why
now and there is a kind of explanation
for that I should also say it's not a
kind of cold war what we are seeing at
the moment because cold war I think is a
war of words it's more than that it's a
real var it's a proxy war between both
of them because you can also see in
different parts of the Radian that are
confronting themselves against each
other
by now I think there is two or three
issues help us understanding this for
example we have Donald Trump in the
America from plays a major role in this
confrontation in this this level because
the last year the Saudis they thought
perhaps Hillary Clinton will be the US
president and he will follow the policy
the foreign policy of Barack Obama which
was not as friendly as what we have seen
under Trump but no Trump is there then
the other point is defeat of is where
because now they have more free room for
showing this confrontation and going to
another higher level of this tension in
this and then we have also nuclear deal
nuclear deal
had a health Iran to play a more
stronger role in this region at that
time they were the Iran was weak and
could not be a rival to Saudi Arabia but
now they have money they can also
support military the sheet here and
there also in this region what have you
got to add to that panoramic explanation
of what you know why now yeah I wanted
to add yeah there's two sides obviously
to this conflict Saudi Arabia and Iran
pitted against each other I think why
now one one point you would have to make
is it has to do with the personality of
the new strongman in in Saudi Arabia the
new Crown Prince I think he
personality shines through he the the
statements coming from Saudi Arabia are
a lot more assertive a lot more
confident some would argue even even
reckless or even adventurous and as as
as Chun she'd said I mean for aside
Arabia the nuclear deal with Iran the
that the West the US and the the other
five nation state was was a wake-up call
they used to know that they can rely on
the US for protection but at that time
and and the the Obama administration's
policies towards Saudi Arabia has become
a lot more critical that that was also
new and in combination with the nuclear
deal Saudi Arabia felt that they have to
start to rely on their own resources
that they have to take charge of their
own security and of their interests and
that's what you see now a lot more
assertive role coming from Saudi Arabia
which clearly fueled the the conflict
with Iran okay Charlie Rose Arnaz from
the Israeli perspective Israel caught
very much between the Front's in this
car in this simmering conflict how does
that feel for the people of Israel
well Israel's are always on edge war is
always looming that's the feeling and
when it comes to Iran as a threat that's
nothing new I mean especially under
President as Prime Minister Netanyahu
it's been a repeating you know threat
that he's mentioning again and again as
his big goal for his administration is
to sort of keep Iran at bay and try to
you know try to find all the possible
ways to sort of curve big on not only
their their nuclear aspirations but you
know what he sees as their plot to sort
of take over as much as they can of the
Muslim world and and have a strong foot
put into the nearest parts of Israel
that is now Syria and Lebanon where so
far he was only you know Lebanon
Hezbollah was known to be a direct
connection to Iran that was something as
well could have sort of unjust
and stand but now with new rules set in
Syria that's that's pushing the in a
little bit too far for the Israelis
that's the feeling yeah and for
Netanyahu it's very much the case it
seems that the enemy of my enemy is my
friend and that's the reason why Israel
is shifting ever closer exactly to Saudi
Arabia exactly that's exactly the only
way to describe the connection between
Saudi Arabia and Israel it's not great
love that there's there I mean both
sides are aware of the dangers the
danger they might you know there's
something dangerous in just a tip like
Israel being friends with any country
definitely the Saudi Arabia but then at
the same time the the rivalry the hatred
toward Iran is just too big and let's
not forget Trump you again I mean
Trump's administration is is is holding
very strong it has very strong
connections both with Saudi Arabia and
Israel and I'm sure that for example
Kushner has a trip to the Middle East
where he makes sure he visits Riyadh but
also Jerusalem encourage and help that
time sheet you're nodding no it's the
same opinion coach now for example that
was there for the third time in the last
months that he was there in Saudi Arabia
they are playing as with these cards and
I think that is the reason why now you
have another level of this tension in
this region I agree and I think the the
Trump administration didn't play a
helpful role it's it seemed that the
visit from Jared Kushner to to Riyadh
seemed to to egg on the the Saudis and
rather than to encourage to embolden
exactly rather than trying to dampen the
the assertiveness so you know I think
the the the trumpet trumpet
administration's role wasn't very
helpful to okay to come and just before
we move on just give us an estimation of
to what extent all that we're talking
about is being played out is a mirror is
a reflection if you will of the great
historic divide between the two strands
of Islam Shia and Sunni well it's clear
that Iran feels it's it's kind of
like the the feels like a protector for
the Shiites in in the region and Saudi
Arabia feel is starting to feel the same
way the the king is called the custodian
of the holy sites meaning in Mecca in
Medina
so the the the conflict between the two
nations is certainly fueled by religious
under undertow that that certainly plays
a big role yeah okay well we've talked
about it already Saudi Arabia is
currently in a massive process of
upheaval it's being described as a
revolution from above and it's being led
by one man in June the elderly Saudi
King Salman bin Abdulaziz also
two-pointed his son Muhammad Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman is just 32
years old and he's now considered the
country's de facto ruler he's carried
out a purge of the ruling elite several
hundred Saudi princes government
ministers and business people have been
arrested allegedly as part of an
anti-corruption Drive the crown prince
is working to consolidate his power base
and to carry out radical reforms but he
has not had much success in curbing the
influence of Iran Saudi Arabia continues
to be bogged down in Yemen's Civil War
and now Lebanon is flaring up again the
prince does have the support of the US
Washington sees the Saudis as key
strategic allies in the region
what role will the crown prince play in
Saudi Arabia's future Mohammed bin
Salman known to his friends I'm told as
his closer allies his MBS what can you
tell us about him as a person as a man
hmm well the first thing that that
striking is is he's very young he's 32
years old he always worked with his
father the current king he was in his
administration the current king was the
governor of Riyadh before the the Crown
Prince now MPs house often to refer to
now what was always his personal
secretary his his the boss of the
administration so he traveled very much
in the shadow of his father his father
became King he now in tune became became
Crown Prince well we don't really know a
lot of aside from that and it's clear he
has the financial means he he bought
last year bought a 500 million dollar
yacht so he's doing quite well and but I
mean it you can't underestimate what
what kind of a revolution he he started
in Saudi Arabia to fight back the the
radical Islam to take on the the Islamic
establishment the Islamic clerics over
are women allowed to drive are women
allowed into sports stadiums and so on
that's it's a huge huge deal in Saudi
Arabia very new and it's it's a huge
deal okay what is what is what is say
here on what are the Iranians make of
all this Iran for sure because the the
problem is the influence of Saudi Arabia
if it's growing through the military
support which is a really a big problem
for Iran not only for Iran I think that
is for the whole
region because if you see there is a
balance there is a balance and that is
their reason why we did not have such a
war between Iran and Saudi Arabia till
now but now after having the support
from United this day just explain again
what exactly is it that is that is
breaking that balance and the military
support the military support of United
States because now they have a more
active role in the this game and if you
see a man been Sal Mohammed bin Salman
has recently said time is on our side if
we think about what it does mean is not
only an empty trade in the direction
Iran towards Iran it's something has in
itself inherent because they are going
to show no the cards is will be
distribute shuffled yeah we can also
play another game this game is no game
over that is a new game and in this new
game we are going to play a major role
in this confrontation with LG and also
with Iran and Shawnee to the Israelis
view the crown prince in Saudi Arabia as
a somebody who is standing for renewal
of his society is he is he a moderniser
or does he have a darker agenda well
honestly Israelis don't really care too
much about what's happening in salads
out here maybe for them this is just a
game it's about the strategic aspect of
it all and once Saudi Arabia becomes far
more you know it was willing to come
closer to Israel then Israel is using it
for it Atlantic advantages as far as it
can Israel is never really Israel's
never really cared too much for human
rights or any other things that
happening within the Middle East in a
sense that it was always clear to Israel
that you know it stands in very
different opposite sides and onward you
know on the values it was interesting
Haaretz carried a line the other day
said Israel is happy to let Riyadh lead
the anti-iranian alliance but not so
happy to pay the political
price of real cooperation what what is
what could the political price all the
political price is first of all
Netanyahu is it has the most right-wing
government we've ever seen in Israel so
of course this is nothing you know
coming closer to Richard to the - to the
Arab world there's nothing that is
taking so fondly within his base but
more than that that it seems to be
understanding that the political process
Orleans to pay is when it comes to the
Palestinians in the sense that they need
to make some some to show willingness
for compromise when it comes to the
Saudi initiative which is quite old
already but it's it's a pizz initiative
that was brought on back on about almost
10 years ago and so and this was
something that Israel always managed to
sort of sort of dodge and avoid but
there's the fear that when when when the
price comes you know the time Capades
to pay comes in the Saudis will sell
we're helping you with the Iranian front
you need to help us with the
Palestinians and that will be a bit of a
tricky exchange for Netanyahu to be
involved in
okay-dokey very interesting you
mentioned during the break when we were
watching that short piece about about
Saudi Arabia and the young Crown Prince
you you had a comment that you wanted to
make about the Shia Sunni divide and the
relevance of that yes I think it's it's
there's no doubt it is important in
understanding the undercurrents of
what's happening in the Middle East and
how its it's it's you know how the
alliances are being you know made but at
the same time it's a bit too simplistic
in the sense that if we look at places
like Turkey we look at places like
Pakistan you know these are places are
actually coming closer to your own and
these are Sunni States and and so what
we're basically seeing is a complete
reshuffle following the the full of Isis
following what was supposed to be the
Arab Spring seven years ago and and and
I'm not sure that the old rules that we
know still apply so easily to the
situation and and and within that we can
see an unbelievable alliances like
Israel so the new game is always a very
dangerous world in the biggest indeed
very much and we cannot forget Russia as
a very dominant force in the region
while you know the Americans kind of
steps took a step back and and of course
the vacuum was filled by the Russians
and and their interest far more than
pampering Iran or anything else is just
keeping stay
on Syria and they will do whatever it
takes and if that means keeping around
close they will they'll also do that
Jamshed Russia the influence of Russia
no less the role of Russia and always
tell us more Russia plays at the moment
a very clear on huge role in the this
area and this in this region not only
because of their alias Iran and Syria
but more than that because because of
step they politic of Barack Obama this
foreign policy of Barack Obama has bring
their position in a match weaker as
prior to death and because of that
Russia could play a major role in this
region we see now is there is a change a
shift toward Aboriginal power no Russia
is not only in Russia will be in Syria
but also in Iran but also in other parts
are playing a really major role okay we
need to talk about Iran we need to talk
about Lebanon a little bit more Donald
Trump the US president has described
Iran as a rogue state whose chief
exports are violence bloodshed and chaos
and Iran is certainly pushing hard for
regional dominance in the Middle East
but it was also negotiated with Western
countries including Germany to reach a
deal designed to prevent it from
producing nuclear weapons in July 2015
huge crowds took to the streets in Iran
to celebrate an international agreement
on the country's nuclear program six
world powers lifted economic
restrictions on Iran in return for
limits on the country's nuclear program
Tehran is now reasserting its influence
in the region
the Saudis consider that a major threat
Iran supports rebel forces in the civil
war in Yemen the Saudis backed the
government
[Music]
Iran has increased its influence in
Syria as a key ally of the Assad regime
Iran has also increased its presence in
Lebanon through its Shiite ally
Hezbollah this has the Israelis very
worried will war break out again in
Lebanon Shani the Israelis are worried
about the prospect of a possible war in
Lebanon is it is it likely is it
inevitable this the feeling is that it
isn't inevitable it's not a question on
if only a question of when
and this also seems to be consensus that
now is not the time yet Israel has
always been very loud about and clear
about the fact that you will not
tolerate any missiles you know being
under the range of missiles shot from
Lebanon you know from Hezbollah to
Israel and of course in danger the
northern part of Israel but can also
reach into the the most populated area
in the center and the biggest
metropolitan of Tel Aviv so in that in
that aspect of course yes there's fear
that's great
mostly you know we were talking about
the Middle East as a new game with all
all cars being we've shuffled there's an
understanding that every tiny mistake
might lead to to to war and might lead
to and you know the the contrary
cautions might be you know very dire so
so as as much as there's very strong
talk and very high words there's also
there's very much caution when it comes
to any fact set on the ground or any any
operations being made so we need to keep
that in mind
role is Iran playing exactly here it's
very difficult to read because on the
one hand there's a sort of a mood of
compromise with the nuclear deal on the
other hand arms shipments and say arms
shipments to Hezbollah to the rebels the
Houthi rebels in Yemen well does Iran
want peace in the Middle East does Iran
want prosperity in the future for its
people I think Iran is like Saudi Arabia
both of them are part of problems and
not
solution in Lebanon name as we see at
the moment I am NOT going to say there
is a real danger of a kind of war but
with the possibility of such a war has
increased and we should take it
seriously and I think at the moment it's
not like that that the war is knocking
on the door in the Libyan or or in
between Iran and Saudi Arabia but there
is another part of this confrontation
for example and economic war is possible
against Lebanon Saudi Arabia can lead to
a kind of restriction of the financial
support for Lebanon which is very very
dangerous for this country
Peter boom you say there definitely will
not be a real full-scale war between
Saudi Arabia and Iran what makes you so
sure that there won't be because I mean
both countries I think aren't prepared
for a war and and I think it's also
clear that no one would gain no no one
would gain from it it wouldn't be a
winnable war everybody still has the
pictures in the mind of the first gulf
war between Iraq and Iran it was
dreadful dreadful war so I think an open
war between a land war between both
countries won't happen the proxy wars
will really go on but but I see another
aspect I mean talking about Iran and
Saudi Arabia there's also the the aspect
of how does the street how does the
population feel about it when we
remember in in January 2016 after Saudi
Arabia executed a prominent Shiite
cleric Nimr al-nimr demonstrators in in
Tehran stormed the saw
mr. Rancic did you know burn part part
of it
so this tensions were high tensions came
down again there was no talk of war but
accidents like this well accidents or
incidents like this can happen so we're
going to see a lot of tension in the
region but as the other said hopefully
no no open no full-scale war between
Iran and Saudi Arabia you the gentlemen
agree on that Shani says almost
inevitable a war in Lebanon but one day
soon soon enough forgive it it within a
year did what is gonna happen next in
the region I think we cannot be sure
about that that there is no var and if
you see every these factors if you see
trees as a forest and not separated from
each other then you come to the
conclusion if you put all of them on the
table I think the option real web VAR
perhaps at the moment is not so actual
and real but their possibility is really
very very very increased second what's
gonna happen the longer we talk the more
scared we get I mean it's it's obvious
yeah but I mean we don't know what's
happening down the line but in the next
few months I don't see it happening okay
thank you very much all three of you for
joining me here on quadriga today our
question has been Middle East tensions
in new war I hope we could leave plenty
of food for thoughts do join us next
week until then bye bye Huntress
[Music]
you